after a weekend of violence between
police and protesters Hong Kong is
business as usual these demonstrations
have become the norm over the last four
months the unrest has threatened the
city's reputation as an international
financial center but on monday the asia
pacific arm of the world's largest
brewer debuted on the Hong Kong Stock
Exchange raising nearly five billion
dollars it's the second largest IPO this
year it's a very good start to reopening
the market this is the biggest Sevilla
the first meaningful you know
large-scale fundraising we've seen for
several months in Asia yes the Hong Kong
continues to be and will be for the
foreseeable future the main main
international both investing and capital
raising venue advisors initial attempt
to list in July was prevented by
political unrest the scale and intensity
of those demonstrations has only
escalated on Sunday Hong Kong witnessed
some of the city's worst violence
protesters set fire to parts of its
business district and government
headquarters was under siege police have
arrested at least 150 people nearly half
of students and one was 12 years old
the weekend's violence is an ominous
sign on the eve of the 70th anniversary
of the founding of the People's Republic
of China the Hong Kong government will
officially host a flag raising ceremony
the Probation groups have also organized
a number of events to celebrate national
day but the anti-government movement
will also come out in force tomorrow
will be a milestone in the movement and
the phase of tyranny we can only fight
like it's a lost battle when the Tator
ship it's a fact revolution becomes a
duty pro-democracy groups have organized
rallies across six districts including a
March in central Hong Kong police have
denied permission to go ahead that's
unlikely to stop a movement that wants
to spoil Beijing's celebrations Sarah
Clark al-jazeera